[Musik]
freitagabend auf der autobahn bei
frankfurt wieder mal fährt jessica zu
ihrer mutter nach hamburg 500 kilometer
entfernung
seit einem schlaganfall ist die mutter
auf unterstützung angewiesen
hallo spart sie wo bist du denn jetzt
gerade erst erlebt seit 20 jahren mit
ihrer familie bei frankfurt ihre mutter
monika in hamburg
[Musik]
wir hatten uns auf ein schönes
wochenende gefreut und plötzlich kam der
anruf aus dem krankenhaus
meine mutter hat mich dann selber
anrufen und sagte also ich bin hier im
krankenhaus und dann hab ich schon auch
ja ich bräuchte nicht kommen das wäre
alles okay so und dann dachte ich nee
ich muss jetzt sofort hingefahren
ja ich hatte natürlich recht große angst
jemand das jetzt weitergehen wie fit
wird sie wieder werden kann dennoch
weiter alleine leben was mache ich denn
jetzt die rentnerin ist jetzt 75 sie
hatte vor sechs jahren einen
schlaganfall
seitdem fährt jessica regelmäßig nach
hamburg ich wünsche mir auf jeden fall
eine selbstbestimmtheit auch im alter
das wird mir das allerwichtigste und
hilfe wenn ich sie brauche
monika hat durch eine rücken-op starke
schmerzen trotz des schlaganfalls
versorgte sich noch weitgehend selbst
kann ich auch ganz schön schwer zu
zugucken wie du das übernimmst warum ja
weil ich mir schwerfällt hallo für mich
machen so ist der grund weshalb du auch
nicht so regelmäßig seine mutter haben
dann kommen die alle sechs wochen
vielleicht ich kann es nicht so genau
sagen aber wir könnten es doch
wenigstens auf der basis von alle zwei
wochen stellen so dass du auch gar nicht
mehr darüber nachdenken muss sondern die
kommt einfach und dann ist das sauber
und dann ist es ziemlich gut warum
nein das ist selbstständigkeit aufgeben
und wecken
du hast noch genug zu tun mit dem
haushalt das ist ein ganz blödes gefühl
so ausgebremst zu sein
mein rat ist total klein geworden und
ich war früher jemand der über
erschwerte die schaufenster konnte mit
meinem roller damals gefahren
und das habe ich so genossen diese zeit
mit noch jedes mal wenn es frühling
kommt denke ich immer ich muss nochmal
ja ich kann ja nicht das geht mir alles
gar nicht mehr den alltag regeln
einkaufen saubermachen lebensmittel
kontrollieren so verlaufen jessicas
besucher bei der mutter er bleibt kaum
zeit um mit monika etwas schönes zu
unternehmen
und wenn ich dann hierher komme dann
komme ich ja wirklich wieso ein
funktions tier hier liste war ein papier
glas wein kaufen regel computer
antennenkabel
hier kommt endlich mal so ein bisschen
schwung rein und ich habe auch phasen wo
ich als auch totale tages bin und monika
lebt allein in ihrer zweizimmerwohnung
ihr erster mann ist gestorben
vom zweiten ist sie geschieden die
rentnerin hat keine familie außer ihrer
tochter die 500 kilometer entfernt wohnt
[Musik]
in deutschland wohnt nur noch ein
viertel der kinder in der nachbarschaft
ihrer alten eltern je weiter die eltern
weg sind desto größer der spagat wenn
sie unterstützung brauchen
besonders für berufstätige kinder
jessica will bei ihren besuchen die zeit
so effizient wie möglich nutzen
dazu gehört der großeinkauf für mehrere
wochen
kannst du doch probieren ich bin zu
wissen
die vorräte sollen bis zum nächsten
besuch reichen
monika kann immer schlechter laufen und
keine schweren taschen mehr tragen
jessica sorge ist es dass ihre mutter
erneut einen schlaganfall erleiden
könnte die nachbarin ist die wichtigste
stütze im haus sie ist die einzige die
nach der mutter schauen kann
falls etwas passiert einfach weil ich
sehr sehr froh sind dass sie so ein auge
auf meine mutter haben die post nicht
dann klingelt schon oder ich ruf durch
den anderen das ist so stabil ist wie
bisher
und wenn sie nicht so oft schmerzen
hätte noch besser gehen
monika macht sich auch sorgen um ihre
lebenssituation so ganz allein
sie möchte eine bekannte vor ort
einbinden die berufs betreuerin ist
sie könnte die betreuung übernehmen wenn
ihre tochter nicht gleich kommen kann
dafür will monika eine verfügung machen
das hast du ausgefüllt im november 2016
unterschrieben offensichtlich auch diese
frage geben und das verstehe ich nicht
weil eine betreuungsverfügung ist ja
letztendlich viel viel mehr als eine
generalvollmacht ich kann bei der
general frei macht alle geschäfte für
dich erliegen
überweisungen rente regeln und und auf
eine betreuungsverfügung heißt dass die
dein vor und ist nichtig ja sie dann ist
da auch was mich in ordnung da hast du
vielleicht recht es ist ja wichtig dass
das du auch sowas unterschreibt aber in
erster linie möchte ich das werden ja
sie wie oft habe ich dich angesprochen
hast uns mal in ruhe reden ist ja nie
geklappt jetzt arbeite ich regelmäßig
also täglich ich kann da nicht einfach
mal eben nach hamburg köpfen und wenn
ich mir vorstelle dass sie hier ins
altersheim gehen würde
und ich müsste den spagat alle zwei drei
wochen machen das würde ich gar nicht
schaffen
also ich bin schon ziemlich unruhig und
ich hätte gerne ein bisschen mir ein
bisschen mehr kontrolle oder ein
bisschen mehr austausch soll jessica die
betreuung ihrer mutter in andere hände
legen oder wäre es eine alternative wenn
monika in ihrer nähe zieht
ich wünsche mir natürlich auch dass du
dann rechtzeitig bei uns in die gegend
ziehst wo du noch so in der lage bist
auch noch neue leute kennenzulernen
freundschaften zu knüpfen und so und das
habe ich von vornherein gedacht ich
werde nicht über ihr leben wollen
das will ich auf keinen fall und da sind
wir uns ja auch klar darüber dass ich
das nicht will und das nicht längst als
ich das erwartet zusammen wohnen wollen
sie nicht aber vielleicht könnte monika
etwas passendes in der nähe finden
ein paar wochen später bei frankfurt
jessica lebt in einem eigenheim mit
ihrem mann und ihrer 15-jährigen tochter
feeling
ihr mann ist häufig auf geschäftsreise
sie kümmert sich neben dem beruf um
haushalt und familie
heute kommt monika zu besuch mutter und
tochter wollen sich ganz konkret
seniorenheime ansehen und dann hast du
klavier und 3 und dann mit der uni los
in dieses altersheim uns das anzugucken
jessica ist 49 und berufstätig sie
arbeitet teilzeit als schul begleiterin
und an den wochenenden an der uni
frankfurt als lese trainerin erklärt sie
studierenden wie sie schneller lesen
lernen können zusätzlich zu ihrem beruf
studiert jessica jetzt
grundschulpädagogik und musik um sich
als lehrerin zu qualifizieren
wenn die mutter in der nähe wohnen würde
wäre das organisatorisch schon eine
erleichterung aber auch eine neue
lebenssituation
die verantwortung ist ziemlich groß wenn
ich hier oder wir hier unsere einzige
anknüpfungspunkt sind nur und dadurch
dass wir in der letzten zeit viel
darüber gesprochen haben und sie sich ja
auch entschieden hat in unsere gegend zu
ziehen
auf einmal ist er in so einer
aufbruchstimmung und sagt ja wie mache
ich es hier und wie mache ich das mit
den möbeln und wer könnte mir dann
helfen beim ausräumen und dann hätte ich
doch so viel zu tun und wie sollen wir
dann das alles machen und jetzt ist es
soweit und jetzt bin ich ganz froh
darüber dass ich den entschluss gefasst
habe wirklich bin nur noch auf der suche
nach einem geeigneten haus
ich möchte auch möglich selbstbestimmt
leben ja das ist mir sehr wichtig
monika soll allein mit dem zug aus
hamburg mit umsteigen in frankfurt einen
anschluss hat sie verpasst
nein
[Musik]
ja genau
mutter und tochter haben sich viel
vorgenommen sie wollen zwei
wohnmöglichkeiten für senioren in der
gegend besichtigen
für ihn ist monikas einzige enkelin die
beiden haben sich schon seit ein paar
monaten nicht gesehen
also ich glaube dass man sich mehr
sorgen hat als ich mir machen weil es
ist eben so dass ich nicht wirklich
immer mitbekomme was alles falsch macht
oder was sie vergisst das kriegt halt
eher die mama mit und für mich ist es
einfach so ist meine omi ssten egal ob
es jetzt mal was vergisst oder so aber
es ist für sie natürlich auch
anstrengend weil ja klar ist ihre mutter
und sie muss sich natürlich auch um sie
kümmern und sie vielleicht beschäftigen
oder mit irgendwo hinfahren von der aber
ich denke schon dass er sich freut weil
gehe da freut sich wenn er kommt für den
nachmittag hat jessica einen termin in
einem seniorenstift im nachbarort
vereinbart die wohn und
pflegeeinrichtung bietet 195 plätze das
haus wird gerade renoviert
gegessen wird im restaurant
die gerichte sind selbst gekocht
kreativgruppen ein fitness programm mit
zahlreichen veranstaltungen wird für die
unterhaltung der bewohner gesorgt
[Musik]
hier kostet ein zimmer ohne pflege grad
1800 bis 1900 euro mit pflege grad liegt
der eigenanteil bei 1400 euro die zimmer
sind etwa 14 quadratmeter groß eigene
möbel können mitgebracht werden
ja klein aber fein würde ich sagen oder
aber der ausblick des falls sich der
gesundheitliche zustand verschlechtert
können die bewohner hier auch gepflegt
werden
schon der ausblick ist das schönste von
einem ja aber die ist ja nicht unbedingt
den brauchst du nicht nicht unbedingt
wie wichtig ist dass ich gut versorgt ja
schon aber wenn du hier den blick nach
wehrheim hast darüber das wäre doch
großartig
dann können wir mal wenig du hast du
brauchst ja im grunde genommen nicht
mehr so viel zeug denkt man aber das ist
der schwierige punkt von west training
aber könntest du leser in sein zimmer
auch vorstellen vielleicht ein bisschen
aber gut auf die park vertrag gut ich
das ist verlässlich und da kann ich mich
gut drauf einstellen aber ich weiß eben
nicht was mich in so einem haus erwartet
und das macht mir auch zu schaffen wenn
ich dann die alten leute so ziemlich
hilflos durch die gegend denen sie und
nicht so ganz wach mir sie im himmel
ich denke sowieso wenn ich den schritt
tun dann ist es der schritt in den tod
so sehe ich das mehr oder weniger kurz
oder lang was ist echt der letzte
schritt den ich dann richtig gemacht
eine alternative zu einem seniorenheim
wäre eine einrichtung für betreutes
wohnen hier haben alle bewohner eine
eigene wohnung
das essen können sie sich selbst
zubereiten aber auch liefern lassen ein
supermarkt ist im haus bei bedarf gibt
es auch eine pflegeabteilung die wohnung
hat zwei zimmer und kostet 1200 euro
miete mit nebenkosten ohne verpflegung
[Musik]
jessica würde ihre mutter auch
finanziell unterstützen bislang war das
nicht nötig ich weiß nicht warum das so
ist wollen wir möchten natürlich wie
gesagt auch selbstbestimmt sein leben
führen auch bis ins höhere alter und
möchte nicht angewiesen seien auf das
geld der tochter oder auf die
unterstützung
da ist eine gewisse scheu die kann man
einfach nicht wegdiskutieren
sie ist einfach da man möchte nicht zur
last fallen wie man so schön sagt
wieder mal eine fahrt nach hamburg
eine lösung ist noch nicht in sicht soll
monika wirklich ihre gewohnte umgebung
verlassen
in die nähe von jessicas familie ziehen
der umzug ist nicht nur ein finanzielles
thema monika braucht zunehmend
unterstützung
jessica will sich verantwortlich um ihre
mutter kümmern
doch wie kann sie das in ihrem alltag
leisten dass sie sich eine eigene
wohnung dass hier eine eigene rungen bei
unserer nähe oder ziehen kann in den
betreuten wohnen zum beispiel was wir
hatten
ich weiß nicht mehr ich glaube ich
glaube fast dass das ein bisschen später
fällt dann beim letzten besuch als bei
uns war da wusste sie wieder nicht wie
man von wäscheständer zusammenklappt für
die kaffeemaschine funktioniert
irgendwie übergelaufen und sie stand
daneben und hat es gar nicht registriert
und das sind so alltägliche sorgen wo
ich so meine zweifel haben uns das noch
so leicht könnte mich darauf einzulassen
dass die beziehung immer mehr in seine
abhängigkeit kommt und dass ich mich
einfach dass ich das nicht in der hand
habe ob sie irgendwie noch geistig klar
ist oder nicht
damit muss das ist ein abschied nehmen
abschied nehmen auch von der vorstellung
dass es sich noch ändern könnte das ist
nicht echt schwer
wie stark ist monikas gesundheit
eingeschränkt kann sie weiterhin alleine
wohl bei diesem besuch will jessica ihre
mutter zum neurologen begleiten
sagen wir genau der richtige moment an
was ich gerne wissen möchte ist ob das
bei dir zusammenhängen
eine körperliche erschöpfung innenstadt
und dann sehr schnell außer atem kommst
und und die
die blutversorgung das habe ich
natürlich
was jetzt herauskommt langsam alt und
liebt
ich stand
was jessica nicht weiß
ihre mutter hat in der letzten zeit
öfter schwindelanfälle und ist auf der
straße schwer gestürzt
die feuerwehr hat sie ins krankenhaus
gebracht monika hat es ihre tochter
nicht erzählt sie wollte sie nicht
beunruhigen denn jessica hatte gerade
prüfungen an der uni
doch sie sagt es beim neurologen
erschrocken dass du solche
schwindelanfälle hast dass du einfach
zusammen sagt hinz das war mir neu und
als wird in den norden das vorhin
erzählt haben er hat er irgendwie immer
gern ich rede hier völlig unbeteiligt
ich denke das ist müsste doch eigentlich
ein alarmzeichen seien ja vielleicht war
das ja so eine art mini staat anteile
oder sowas
jetzt mal sehen wie gut ist freiwillig
ich weiß es ja nicht immer so viel
risiko riesen haben das war alles weg
geschoben
für mich ist allerdings auch ein
alarmzeichen dass meine mutter mir das
mich erzählt ja wie soll ich dann eine
kontrolle darüber haben wie es hier
wirklich geht
in der prüfungsphase hätte ich damals in
der prüfungsphase aber ich meine jetzt
so machen nein ist das für mich schon
schon eher ein argument dafür dass das
so bald zu uns ziehen sollte ist damit
ich das mit kriege ich sehe hier bleibe
liebsten hat man genau am liebsten schon
genau klar man darf ja nicht vergessen
dass das eine dass ich manchmal
hochgradig genervt bin und wütend auf
die ärzte wütend auf meine mutter wütend
auf irgendwie alles ja und ich nicht
mehr machen kann als ich tun kann also
[Musik]
das ist nicht so dass ich dann irgendwie
ruhig schlafen kann manchmal noch
manchen telefonaten oder erlebnissen
weil meine mutter mir nebenbei erzählt
sie wäre gestürzt waren krankenhaus ja
dann gehe ich nicht beruhigt schlafen
zu hause allein in hamburg monika hält
sich mit feldenkrais fit ich möchte es
ja eigentlich ersparen diese sorge um
mit das würde hier gerne sparen ja aber
kann man sich doch nicht aussuchen ist
schön das ist sie gibt wie viele haben
keine kinder
melde dich doch mal ich kann ich nicht
erreichten okay okay bis bald hallo frau
jessica peter hallo ja ist schon eine
ganze weile herum ganz direkt zu sein
ich bin ein bisschen unruhig ich habe
meine mutter nicht erreicht auch nicht
auf dem handy und könnten sie vielleicht
einfach mal untergehen und nach ihr
gucken ob sie da ist ob es ihr gut geht
also ich empfinde das hier auch so dass
ich sehr viel allein bringen und das
gefällt mir eigentlich auch nicht haben
wir das habe ich nicht die kraft nur
noch mehr aktivitäten zu starten
es reicht nicht das was ich mache
verschiedene termine lisa und weil ich
bin hier zufrieden damit
aber diese große einsamkeit ist allein
sein und das ist mir fällt nur
eingesetzt wenn es ihre schmerzen zu
lassen geht monika rausch auch in den
tierpark ist es besser allein zu sein in
der gewohnten umgebung in hamburg oder
soll sie doch in die nähe der tochter
ziehen
die entscheidung muss nun bald getroffen
werden
[Musik]
jessica ist wieder unterwegs nach
hamburg diesmal will sie kerstin treffen
eine bekannte ihrer mutter die als
berufsbetreuer arbeitet monika hatte sie
damals um einen entwurf für eine
betreuungsverfügung gebeten
wenn monika in hamburg bleibt könnte
kerstin die betreuung vor ort übernehmen
wenn jessica nicht verfügbar ist
jessica hatte anfangs starke bedenken
aber ich bin erleichtert dass du sagst
du würdest du cerstin gammelin im weil
es mir doch auch sehr entgegenkommt am
anfang als wir darüber sprachen waren
bei allen noch nicht so wirkt wie heute
und da war eine abbildung sehr groß und
ich habe mich gleich zurück ich weiß
ehrlich gesagt immer noch nicht weiter
was ich tun soll
weil es geht ja darum meine mutter hinzu
uns zieht oder noch länger hierbleibt
und ich hatte den norden auch einfach
nur um sie in eine einschätzung gebeten
und er sagt ja ja so aus medizinischen
gründen ist es immer gut an den also
jemanden dort zu belassen wo er ist
würde ich würde ich auch er vorschlagen
stell dir vor du müsstest dich jetzt
komplett in einem fremden umfeld also
recht finden ohne irgendwelche
persönlichen privaten kontakte außerhalb
deine tochter
das ist ein bisschen sehr schwierig also
gerade im alter finde ich das würde ich
dir vor ich also würde ich da wirklich
empfehlen so lange wie möglich hier zu
bleiben
das möchte ich natürlich
die entscheidung ist gefallen monika
wird in hamburg bleiben
fc köln nun ein netz von unterstützung
knüpfen
ein hausnotruf gibt sicherheit damit
monika jederzeit hilfe holen kann
der bedarf ist groß das gerät wird
mehrfach nicht geliefert zusätzlich hat
jessica einen antrag bei der
pflegeversicherung gestellt um einen
pflege grad zu bekommen muss der
medizinische dienst monika begutachten
jessica will dann unbedingt dabei sein
ich wollte einfach nur kurz besprechen
dass das auch klappt es ist halt sehr
früh schläft bis 10 oder so also kriegen
sie sie so desolat wie sie sein soll ja
die to do listen werden immer länger
jessica bereitet ihren nächsten besuch
in hamburg vor neben den üblichen
aufgaben einkäufe arzttermine und
bürokratie steht nun die begutachtung
bevor er sie körper nicht ständig hin
und her pendeln wenn monika weiterhin in
ihrer wohnung bleibt dann muss
zusätzliche betreuung organisiert werden
dabei geht es auch um die finanzierung
insgesamt gibt es fünf pflege gerade bei
pflege grad eins bedeutet das eine
kleine entlastung von 139 euro
die einstufung hängt vom gutachter ab
[Musik]
das ist schwammig an bereiten naja warum
sagt tom geschäft oder wenn ich ihn
selbst und vom nächsten möglichen den
stuhl nehmen ja und geht es mit dem
schreiben an setzen jawohl vblock es
geht ja heute um ihren antrag bei der
pflegeversicherung bildung das schickt
mich der medizinische dienst heute
zugeben ich bin dort pflegefachkraft und
dafür heute so ein bisschen gucken was
bei ihm los ist und wie es ihn so geht
wobei sie unterstützung brauchen ja dann
wäre ich heute mal ein bisschen mit
schreiben hier wollen sich einfach mal
so ein bisschen erzählen was ist da los
bei ihnen ja ich kann mich nicht gut
bewegen und ich bin immer sehr
eingeschränkt so mit den schmerzen
ja wo kommt das her ja ich hatte eine
rücken-op vor fast zehn jahren ja und
seitdem bin ich eingeschränkt also ich
will meine mutter insofern unterstützen
dass die ansprache hat im alltag dass
jemand nach ihr sieht einmal die woche
das auch jemand ordnung macht weil sie
das überhaupt nicht sieht sie überhaupt
ja behauptet ja immer noch sie könne ja
selber putzen aber sie macht es nicht
also die unterstützung brauche ich auf
jeden fall für sie dazu soll jetzt
endlich der hausnotruf geliefert werden
jessica muss dringend nach frankfurt
zurück wieder ist die hilfe der
nachbarin gefragt
denn das kommt und ich bin zu hause dann
kann ich dann runter gehen das kein
problem
ja ja ich habe ja auch einen schlüssel
kennen der notdienst kommt und sie nicht
auf dann könnte ich ja runter gehe aber
das wäre ja ich muss mich sogar zu
langsam daran gewöhnt es sich jetzt doch
immer jemand an der seite habe er sich
kümmert was ich sonst immer selber gern
gemacht habe und was das alter angeht
bin ich natürlich auch sehr kritisch und
auch ängstlich was wird da auf mich
zukommen
und ja es das thema eigentlich man will
es nicht haben
dann will es nicht
[Gelächter]
monika hat pflegestufe eins bewilligt
bekommen ihr alltag ist besser
organisiert doch die beste lösung gibt
es nicht
jessica wird weiterhin regelmäßig zu
ihrer mutter nach hamburg fahren
[Musik]